we are ready to discuss our next
European budget over the past weeks we
have worked very hard to unify the
different positions we need to maintain
a strong support for the convergence
between member states and regions
through trade and policy and agriculture
support for farmers and ensuring food
quality at the same time we want to
modernize our approach we need more
resources more innovation to confront
our two major transitions climate change
and the digital transformation this is
not about virtual money we are talking
about more than one thousand billion
euros for the next seven years for real
investments in trendlines infrastructure
schools and Erasmus program green energy
our common defense security and
migration we have to invest in research
and development and our space program if
we want to be in the front line we aim
at more efficiency more fairness and
flexibility the rule of law and good
governance is a priority to the own
resources on plastic waste carbon
emissions and others are part of the
debate that would be current with the
European Green Deal the next budget is
an important tool to implement our
priorities but it's not enough we need
more strategic investments that's why I
have proposed to increase the capital of
the European Investment Bank which could
mobilize up to 500 billion euro giving a
strong boost for innovation digital and
climate transition is needed no more
than ever
what's at stake
is our prosperity our quality of life
and the future of our next generations
everything is on the table waiting will
not make things easier it's time to
decide